Hey, this is Brian from Fullstack Egg. In the last video, we saw Papillis NGX turn
farm paperwork into a searchable archive. And while that's already useful, the
normal search could still be better. With the built-in search, you have to know
the words the document actually used. So if I search for fertilizer recommendations,
Papillis comes back empty. Now I know those records exist. They are just named
things like Nutrient Management Plan, and they mention products like ammonia
instead of the words I typed. Papillis Egg fixes that by adding semantic search.
It doesn't replace Papillis NGX, and it doesn't modify the install itself. It
runs beside it as a companion Docker container, and it reads the text Papillis
already extracted. So it builds a local search index based on meaning rather than
keywords. And what Papillis Egg is going to do is expose those search tools to
cloud or any AI agent through MCP. MCP stands for Model Context Protocol, and
it's just the standard way for an AI agent to connect to external tools. So
now I can ask the question the way I would say it out loud. What are my
fertilizer recommendations? And Claude calls the Papillis Egg Search tool, searches
the archive by meaning, and it finds the nutrient plans that the keyword search
missed. And that's the difference with adding semantic search. I don't have to
remember the exact title or product name, I can just describe the thing I need. And
Claude knows how to bring back the right documents. And Papillis Egg indexes the
documents on your server without modifying your Papillis NGX data. So your
Papillis install stays stock, and Papillis Egg just adds the smarter layer
right beside it. And that's it today, so thanks for watching.